Donald Trump gave another one of these
rambling incoherent speeches that were
so bizarre that you couldn't tell
whether the teleprompter switched to
Mandarin in the middle of the speech or
maybe Trump was having some kind of
medical incident because no sensible
explanation came to mind other than
total incompetence and we know that
Donald Trump recognized that the public
relations around caging little kids was
bad who could have guessed right and so
in an attempt to fight back against what
Trump saw as bad publicity about his
immigration policy he put together
people whose family members were
allegedly clip killed by quote criminal
illegal aliens here's a little bit of
Donald Trump's bizarre rambling
incoherent speech we're gathered today
to hear directly from the American
victims of illegal immigration you know
you hear the other side you never hear
this side you don't know what's going on
these are the American citizens
permanently separated from their loved
ones the word permanently being the word
that you have to think about permanently
they're not separated for a day or two
days they are permanently separated
because they were killed by criminal
illegal aliens these are the families
the media ignores they don't talk about
them now you might say hey David that's
not deceptive there are illegal
immigrants who killed people and these
are the families of their victims so
what's wrong with that shouldn't we know
if there are criminal illegal aliens and
I would say to you sure that's a problem
we should focus on all people in the US
who commit violent crimes whether
they're here legally or not the problem
is that when you have to stop and think
about why Donald Trump did this rally
and gave the speech the insanity of it
surfaces the bad PR is around the
separation of children from their
families the separation of children from
parents who aren't even breaking laws in
some cases because they're coming to the
border and seeking asylum not entering
the United States illegally and Donald
Trump is pushing back against critics
who say caging kids is bad by saying
some illegal immigrants killed people
he's holding the rally to make people
afraid of dangerous immigrants and then
of
course the biggest insanity insanity of
this all is that undocumented immigrants
commit less crime than native-born
Americans we have data from the
libertarian Cato Institute about
criminality in Texas and what you will
see is that native-born Texans commit
crimes including all crimes in general
but also specifically homicide and
larceny at higher rates than both
documented and undocumented immigrants
so if you're holding a rally merely to
warn people about who's dangerous by
crime rate you have to be way more
afraid of in this case native-born
Texans than undocumented people in Texas
one more set of data for you at the
state level higher rates of undocumented
immigrants correlate to a lower crime
rate from 1990 to 2014 the data is clear
we did an entire long-form piece about
this on the truth about illegal
immigration you can find out more about
this issue by checking out that video
last thing on this the economic side I
hate to break it to anybody who's
finding comfort and solace in the
immigrants are bad because they're
taking our jobs thing but if you lost
your job to an immigrant shouldn't you
be blaming the business owner who took
advantage of the immigrant at your
expense to lower their costs and
increase their profits the people hiring
the immigrants are the ones that are
laughing all the way to the bank because
you're mad at the immigrants instead of
them this is free-market capitalism or
at least it's what I call it Pat is free
where we want it to be free capitalism
and I know we've gone over this before
but how can the immigrants be both lazy
welfare recipients vagabonds who don't
want to work and taking so many jobs
that real Americans like you can no
longer fight find one explain that to me
and you'll never see Republicans blame
the business owners who hire these
illegal immigrants now don't give them a
tax cut every once in a while they will
say and we should also enforce the law
when it comes to businesses that hire
undocumented immigrants but they don't
really have the political will to do it
absolutely immoral what is happening
here you can discuss this with us on our
subreddit at david pakman.com
/re d di t